hi there steve kaufman here uh something
new that i want to try
i want to try a hangout which is a form
of
video conferencing on google plus
um nine people plus me that's a total of
10 can be actively involved and all
their
little videos will appear on the screen
other people can follow it because it'll
be broadcast
so i want to talk about language
learning i want to talk about link and
how to use it especially the the new
version and some of the changes that
we've made but also about language
journey learning in general and some of
the principles behind links so i'll tell
you right up front that's what i'm going
to be talking about
um
it'll be primarily in english but if
people want to ask questions in other
languages that's fine if i'm capable of
answering uh in those languages
um the time is 11 o'clock
pacific standard time in north america
which is
2 p.m on the east coast of north america
i think it's around 7 or 8 o'clock in
the evening in europe and i think it's
in the middle of the night in asia so
it's probably not so convenient for asia
uh
i would like if this we work out all the
problems i would like to do this uh from
time to time in different languages
and at time zones that are convenient
for different parts of the world so we
could do it in russian at a time that's
convenient for russia we could do it in
portuguese at a time that's convenient
for people in brazil and or portugal we
could do it at a time that's convenient
for people in japan or china uh
so that or europe with spanish and
german and french
uh so we but i think in the first one we
will try to do it in english so once
again and oh and the way you can join in
this is you have to come to google plus
to the link page at google plus and i
will put the url of that link page at
google plus
underneath the video here in the
explanations and so you go there and you
follow the link page so yeah it's
connected with links some people are
going to say that i'm just promoting me
but of course i am
but we're going to have fun with it at
the same time
come and
follow me at google plus then i will be
able to include you in the hangout if
you're interested and so we'll take the
first nine people will be in the
discussion and the others will be able
to follow it
and so once again we'll be talking about
language learning and link it'll be at
the google plus
link page and we'll be using the google
plus hangout
technology so and i don't work for
google plus but i had a look at their
video conferencing you know hangout
technology and it looks very very
convenient and easy to use so i hope to
see some of you
uh tomorrow and it will be broadcast to
everyone who is subscribed to
my youtube account i gather if we do
everything right so looking forward to
seeing some of you tomorrow thank you
for listening bye for now